more on our top story now the Sky News
investigation revealing an increased
threat of a terror attack in the UK it's
not just in Britain that the so-called
Islamic state is inspiring attacks well
let's take a look at some recent
examples elsewhere that show why the
authorities must take such threats
seriously at the end of last year three
people were killed after armed police
stormed a cafe in Sydney in Australia
where is inspired gunman man Haron
moni's had taken 17 people hostage in
January coordinated attacks in Paris
were carried out involving a shooting at
satirical magazine Charlie Hebdo and an
attack at a kosher grocery store in
February police in Copenhagen shot dead
suspect omar el Hussein over the murders
of two people and wounding zuv five
police officers the first shooting took
place at an event discussing freedom of
speech in the wake of the January Paris
terror attacks in march two gunmen in
tunis stormed the Bardo National Museum
killing 21 people including 17
foreigners back in France and suspect
Yassen sally was arrested in the
southeast in june / beheading his boss
and setting off a blast at a chemical
factory and on the same day 30 Britons
were among 38 tourists killed when
gunmen sayfudine res Gris opened fire on
soos beach in Tunisia well let's peek
now to mubeen Hussain who's the founder
of British Muslim youth he joins us now
live via Skype from Yorkshire very good
evening to you what Sky News has found
in this investigation that actually is
tactics could change are changing to
recruit people leave them in their own
country in this occasion the UK and take
it from there is this a a worrying trend
as far as you're concerned well I think
is quite shocking and worrying for
everybody out there I was asked a
question it worrying for children of
Muslims well i think is worrying out
there for everybody you know you've
named a lot of the attacks that have
happened by Isis and if you look at the
attacks that Isis have a certain type of
ideology that believes in the end of
world type of ideology we're only there
their way of life can flourish and they
take no casualties so you've seen a high
portion of Muslim casualties in this
you've seen Sonny's and sufis and Shias
and Coptic Christians and Westerners and
you know I think this is a very shocking
revelation and it shows failure within
government policy as well the Prime
Minister came out in a government
strategy to suggest that passports of
young children that may be vulnerable to
go out to Syrian Iraq that might be
seized but if Isis are changing their
strategy and this is going to be British
people on British soil and I think we
really need to come together and get it
rips with it well being most of those
attacks are I mentioned there that we
listed involves people who had traveled
to is training camps or at least been
out of the country if if the targeting
of people is within their own country we
sort of assume that there must be some
sort of brainwashing going on in order
for them to follow this ideology how's
the brainwashing being so successful do
you think if it is all via social media
via the Internet surely there needs to
be some contact some commuted community
cohesion there well that's not a
brilliant question there I think I would
answer that question a look at I in two
different parts i think firstly my
opinion and my assessment on that says
suggest that there's three major factors
within that so foxy i think a lot of
people have I'm not here to say that
foreign policy leads somebody to go and
blow themselves up or go outside and
kill people but for impoverished foreign
policy you can't kill hundreds and
thousands of people in Iraq in foreign
policy and certain types of other
foreign policy and expect nothing to
happen I think they are factors that
alienate people that are actually ignite
you know I hate or a confusion within
people and then you have the second
factor which is alienation we've had a
huge a high in the proportion of
Islamophobia that is risen within this
country within the within Europe and
throughout the world because of is and
other things so that's resulted in
schools having horizon Islamophobia
driver some phobia the streets of London
for the most multicultural cities in the
world I think this caused alienation but
yeah I agree that is ideology there is
an ideology of this quality ideology
that they profess where they suggest
only their way of life can succeed and
we've seen that that actually leads to
brainwashing people and a lot of things
do happen online but we need to come
together and work SOT giclee on this the
Prime Minister has actually discussed
that you know that the successes that
have happened from the Muslim community
but it's now time for the Muslim
community I'm the Prime Minister to come
together and work together as one I
would actually ask the government to
have a collective approach on this not
just a government approach but to bring
in the opposition to bring in all
political parties and all sides of the
debate all on one platform to actually
discuss this because we need to have a
clear strategy on it what was your
theory I mean we know that is aims to
create this Caliphate to create a huge
swath of land across Europe parts of
Africa as well and at least that they
want to control why then attack Western
tile targets why then attack within
Britain but without this question asked
time and time again we've had
policymakers researchers academics
politicians men's in many suits actually
sit in a room and you know discuss why
why is the reasons and why are the
factors and this is why my organization
along with faith lattice has actually
launched the first of its kind a
national youth consultation let's not
ask men in academia or in politics why
their factors are out there but why
don't we actually go to the grassroots I
actually go to young British Muslims who
is are trying to get in contact with via
social media and ask then what the
driving factors are as young bration
Muslims what are the vulnerability and
the factors because they are the people
are the real important people within
this debate but for so long have not
been actually questioned or even being
brought into the debate which is packed
which I found quite profound we have
also other types of organizations are
actually work on an accusation and
dealing with Islamist
ideologies but don't want to work with
Muslims I think one of the things we
must do is speak to grassroot Muslims
and ask them what other vulnerabilities
what are the factors why they may see an
appeal what you know concerns are they
have I think for me as a young British
Muslim I see you know whenever there's
an attack by is that is this profound
belief that i am must come out and
condemn these actions i do condemn them
I don't condemn them just as a Muslim I
condemn these acts of barbarism as a
human being like my fellow Muslims and
my fellow British people throughout this
country okay mubeen you saying thank you
very much for joining us moving is the
founder of the British Muslim youth
thank you